[Music]
what do you think do you think there's a
future
relationship between christmas and islam
do you hear about santa
so not knowing it they are celebrating
the birthday of a muslim man
it's been turned into big money big
industry um it all starts with some
innocent fun
when you are reading your own bible
comes next 25th of december they have to
have the tree
when we are saying merry christmas we
are saying mary shirk
or happy shark he was a jew but you're
saying he's a muslim how could how can
you qualify that statement
jesus peace be upon him obviously he was
a muslim he was a middle eastern and he
was a man
where people are wishing people merry
christmas you're hearing about santa
decorating of trees and you have a a lot
of muslims
also who are out there who are falling
into the celebration so we want to talk
about the celebration of christmas
christmas we want to talk about the
christmas tree santa claus
and everything else that goes along with
it with my next guest
dr sabil ahmed
so pleased to be here how are you it's
great to have you back on the show
alhamdulillah
i want to get into this video and from
there we can take off
with talking a little bit about the
history and other relevant points that
revolve
around christmas how's that
alhamdulillah sounds good let's go
a christmas business
[Music]
[Music]
sugar
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
typical for this time of year right not
for some people
in case you didn't know muslims don't
celebrate christmas
right-wing hosts and twitter users were
furious that muslims would be included
in a christmas ad
the anger was instant and overwhelming
but it's not
all wrong for example i've never once
celebrated christmas
i've never gotten a tree never hung
lights i was raised by conservative
parents to believe that even saying
merry christmas meant acknowledging
jesus was born in december which would
jeopardize my relationship with god
so what exactly am i doing hauling this
christmas tree with my wife mira into
our home
i'm not exactly sure a part of me is a
shame
what do you think do you think there's a
future relationship between
christmas and islam all right so what
are your first reactions when you see
this actually spreading it's actually
becoming a little bit more mainstream
now
like when i opened up the program i said
that
you have a lot of muslims undertaking
many of these celebrations and then you
can see
it's santa's coming to town and in
beirut and other muslim majority
countries what do you think when you see
that
i went to jordan and then from there to
from there to philistine
two years ago when i went there almost
every shopping center
almost on every street every corner
there was a christmas tree
and i was thinking to myself if these
muslims if they realize
the actual history and the facts
about christmas and the christmas tree
they would be just running away from it
may allah
give you know keep on guiding us and uh
helping us to educate others about the
realities of their celebrations
yeah i mean when you say running away
from it
it's a fact you have many christians
running away from it
more booze is so then more suicide takes
place then more marriages break up then
more kids are neglected and abused then
more drugs are consumed then
it's the day when the devil has his due
and so
there's no santa claus yo mama or your
dad you bought them presents
there is no santa claus and ain't no man
falling 500 pounds coming down your
chimney
and live and talk about it not today
stop lying this is hedonism hedonism
this is paganism that's right this ain't
got nothing to do with god
so we're actually imitating many
and many of the christians who actually
look into the bible they point out
themselves that this is something that
they
who want to really be committed to
following the bible properly
they also stay away from it but then
it's odd that you see muslims
some muslims running towards it you know
as that lady she mentioned
it sounds so fun right so the word fun
is there
it's an innocent you know it's an
innocent celebration the kids are going
to have a good time it's fun
that's how innovations they get started
so it's important that there are some
christian groups for example jehovah's
witnesses
for example the seven day adventists
they know the reality
of where the 25th of december came into
they know the reality of decorating the
christmas trees for that reason they
don't celebrate christmas
if we put things in perspective if you
just because now it's kind of
like you you really want to uh go out of
your way
and fit in you want to go ahead and go
out of your way
to not offend anybody but why should it
be that way i mean just like for
instance
you know a it's an example has been
struck where
for instance you know we wouldn't expect
let's say a hindu
to wish us happy eid right
because now during the time of eid right
we're doing imitating
abraham who sacrificed iran at that time
or muslims who might eat
wheat beef burgers for instance but now
the
the hindus they end up worshiping the
cow right
so asking the hindu to go ahead and
celebrate
or hindus celebrating that that would
just go against their beliefs because
what they look at that is blasphemy of
what we're doing but we don't take no
offense to that i mean
right right because what the christians
are doing is
they celebrate christmas but if they
know
if they know that who was jesus and if
the muslims
kind of find out what do they believe
about jesus they take him to be god and
son of god and divine
came down to save the humanity from our
sins
so all of them according to the quran is
committing or associating partners with
god
so when we are celebrating christmas or
when we are
saying merry christmas we're actually
giving credibility to those celebrations
we're actually saying to them you know
what you're committing shirk
and we congratulate you in it that's how
it is
in reality even though the muslims don't
mean that but that's how it comes out
that if they are doing something which
contradicts the quran and the sunnah
and even on christianity we are actually
congratulating them
and you know encouraging them to
continue that yeah
yeah i think that's that when we talk
about tolerance understanding
it's not where like you have in
different countries where people
are forcing muslim women not to wear
hijab
right so now you're intruding on
someone's god-given right they're trying
to
do what god told them to do to observe
that modest dress code just like jesus
mother mary
but you have people forcing them to not
do that to live
their way of life so now if people want
to celebrate
this holiday right if they're christian
and they want to sell it or others
muslims are not coming and trying to
you know ban them from from following
that's their religious holidays their
religious right we talk about it and
that but that's just the point now
where where we can have differences but
we can
acknowledge that they exist in a benign
nice way
but now when you have also what but when
people are getting offended why you're
not like we don't
we just don't get offended someone
doesn't celebrate eid right that's we
don't expect them to
yeah why would you expect a muslim to
celebrate a holiday
that's not his but going to the next
level but then muslims feeling like they
have to do that that's the odd thing
that's the
that's the yeah there's the inferiority
complex as they say
fine if someone is doing it it is their
business may allah guide them
the best that we can do is we can
educate them we can educate our own
families and children
that this is the reality of their
celebrations and allah has given us
you know some other celebrations which
are better
which are attached to to the pleasing of
god
which are attached to the noble examples
of all the these companions
and the prophets so we need to educate
on both sides
the realities of this side and the
realities of our side and how we should
be celebrating
you know our celebrations yeah so this
could be i mean
primarily focused to help educate
muslims who have chosen who
go by uh that name tag you know that
title that god almighty has given us in
the quran those who have submitted their
will to the creator of the heavens and
earth and now
one of the things that stood out here is
that she was saying and many would argue
well this
has nothing to do with with my
with my religious beliefs it's just the
cultural thing and we're just
showing that you know we can bond also
with you guys in this so it doesn't
conflict
our religious beliefs how would you
answer that
well so she may have that intention yeah
you know may allah guide her may
give hidayah she has that intention but
the children who are celebrating with
her
maybe later on they may not have that
intention they may be thinking you know
what
comes next 25th of december they have to
have the tree
they they now they expect the presents
to be there
and now their generations to come it
just
becomes almost obligatory now for them
and down the line it just becomes
part of a muslim's life it's not just
fun or culture
and now it becomes you know we have to
do it if someone is not doing it
people look at it how come you're not
celebrating christmas where is your tree
so that's the harm it all starts with
some innocent fun
yeah and then the future generations
they just take it as as if this is part
of their deen
yeah and that's you know so so that's
the harm of that
i heard you say something uh that
people are celebrating the
the muslim man in the desert uh can you
elaborate on that what were you um you
made a video about this right
so jesus peace be upon him obviously he
was a muslim
he was a middle eastern and he was a man
so whenever christian brothers and
sisters in humanity the 2.2 billion of
them when they celebrate christmas
they are celebrating the birth of a
muslim man from the middle east who had
a beard
who worshipped one god who used to greet
with the greeting of assalam alaikum
he used to pray like the muslims he was
a muslim so not knowing it they are
celebrating the birthday of a muslim man
but if someone says no how's that he was
a christian no but he was
and some will say he was a jew but
you're saying he's a muslim how could
how can you qualify that statement
okay so so a muslim is a person who is a
submitter to the creator
so that's the arabic definition of it
that's what the actual meaning of the
actual meaning of it correct obviously
doesn't mean
arab in the desert well i mean no not
so the word islamic means submission to
god
and the follower of islam is called as a
muslim so anyone who submits only to one
god
obeys only god do not worship idols and
humans and creation
that person in a generic term we say
he's a muslim
so jesus was a muslim in fact according
to the quran according to the bible both
he used to submit himself to one god
like john chapter 5 verse number 30 says
i do the will of the father that i of
myself i cannot do anything whatever i
hear i judge my judgment is true
because i seek not my own will but the
will of god who sent me
so anyone who submits their will to the
will of the higher power creator allah
is busy in arabic that person will label
them as muslims
and the word christian came after jesus
peace be upon him
he never heard the word christian or
christianity
even the word judaism is not there in
the whole bible
the word christianity is not there in
the world in the whole bible
but the concept of absolute submission
to god is there in the bible
and jesus used to submit himself to god
so for that reason we say
his faith is islam and he is a muslim
that makes sense i usually also like
qualifying these or defining these words
when someone asks
are you a muslim i say well what do you
mean by muslim i usually ask what do you
mean
because we want to get out in the open
like what are they thinking right
because if they
their definition is uh
it's not according to their definition
because you'll be surprised some people
because of much of the mainstream
mainstream media propaganda
and much of the hate machine people have
in their head muslim and they'll think
okay this is arab in the desert
you know some terrorists or et cetera et
cetera but then you just
beautifully uh describe the actual
meaning
of what and this is very important that
people know the meanings of these words
islam muslim uh how about the word uh
christmas let's let's define that what
does this mean where did they come from
so the word christmas has two words
attached to it the word mass
right christ and mass so christ is
coming from obviously prophet jesus
he's the messiah according to the quran
in many places surah 5 ayah
75 surah 3 ayah number 70
73 and many places he is described or
the title is the messiah messiah means
somebody who is anointed
so so the word christ is not the last
name of jesus
important so it comes from the word
christos
and christos is a greek word for christ
so when we say that jesus is christ so
we're saying that he's anointed by god
so christ does not mean that somebody
who is divine somebody who is
uh you know god son of god it is just a
title
and many titles are given to different
prophets and messengers
so the word christmas is coming from
christ and the word mass
mass means the service like muslims when
we go to the jummah prayer the friday
prayer
we have our service so for them their
service their sunday saturday service is
called as a mass
yes so christmas is the mass the service
around the person of christ jesus
do we actually know his birthday
well no one knows his birthday on the
island
because it's it's put out there as if
it's december
25th is that his actual birthday well
the bible does not say
in any place that he was born on the
25th of december number one
in fact the bible says in the gospel of
matthew the shepherds they were you know
out there with their sheep and their
goats
and that usually happens in spring and
fall not in not in
december number third important as
the followers of christ as they were
going to different
other cultures and lands in those
cultures and lands the concept of
trinity was prevalent
and they used to have their own versions
of trinity and their own gods
right quote-unquote guards and those
guards were born
on the 25th of december according to
them according to their mythology
like mithra for example he's a persian
son of god
part of the trinity born on the 25th of
december had 12 disciples
was born to a virgin died and raised on
the third day
so christianity bordered from that
culture they also borrowed from the
egyptian trinity
the osiris and the isis trinity they
also borrowed from the from the greek
myth
from the greek you know fables so all of
these guards of that time the false
guards obviously
they were born on the 25th of december
so christian so christians for the sake
of fun i'm not sure what was their
what was their reasoning they attached
the 25th of december to the birth of
jesus
bible doesn't say anything about it in
fact this happened three centuries
after jesus peace be upon him he was
gone
so for the first two centuries what
about his his disciples
you know those closest to him was there
any celebration of that in
of that day for the first two centuries
by the disciples of jesus in fact
according to the bible
according to also encyclopedia
britannica the early disciples of
christ for two centuries they rejected
the celebration of any birthdays
because according to them celebrating
birthdays is
imitating the pagans so they were like
really strong
in rejecting anything that has to do
with polytheism
and paganistic rituals and beliefs so
jesus did not celebrate it the bible is
silent about the word christmas and the
celebration
the 200 years none of the disciples
celebrated christmas yeah
so if our christian friends would like
to be like jesus we want to be like
jesus
if they want to be like jesus they
should not celebrate his birthday they
should follow the same belief
that he had which is absolute monetism
submission
to the creator yeah what do you say when
someone will point out say well why are
you guys
talking about this his birthday when you
guys are celebrating the birthday of
prophet muhammad
yeah there's uh some muslims they
celebrate the birthday of prophet
muhammad peace be upon him
but again if we are going to go back to
our two main sources
the quran which is the word of allah and
the authentic examples of prophet
muhammad peace be upon him
none of them they tell us to celebrate
the birthday of muhammad peace be upon
him in fact allah says in the quran
surah 5 ayah 3
that the faith has been completed it has
been completed
so we need to look at did the prophet
celebrated his burden no he did not
did the companions of muhammad peace be
up upon him celebrated
none of them they did so we need to
follow them
the quran says to follow muhammad peace
be upon him right surah
surah 33 ayah number 21 that luchador
that in the person of muhammad peace be
upon him you have the best example to
follow
for those who believe in allah in the
last day and remembers allah much
he never celebrated and we want to be
like him
do you see when you contrast you see the
earlier companions
disciples of jesus and what they
were upon you talk about they're on the
pure monotheism calling people to only
worship the one and only created
heaven's earth
after they they he leaves the scene
they start they leave the scene now can
you see contrast same thing here when
you look at
with islam you see kind of you know from
what they were upon
right the quran the verbatim word of god
almighty and the example the sunnah
jesus had his sunna his way right and
those companions
at his time were following his way so
then you point these things out it's
very interesting and then you have the
same thing the last and final master
problem muhammad
then he has his companions but as time
drifts off do you see the same thing
happening where people start to just
go further further away from the
the original way exactly exactly
and obviously people may have done it
they may have good intentions
when they looked into you know some
hindus and persians and other people
having certain rituals certain
celebrations let's just do it for the
sake of fun we are not celebrating their
ideology or their spirituality
let's just have you know some innocent
fun
that's how these innovations they get
started and now eventually they become
part of islam
so we say that the early followers of
christ they were muslims
and now the faith turned into
christianity how did it
happen monotheism got diluted
slowly the cultural things and the
spiritual things of other cultures they
got into the faith
and now the whole faith is
unrecognizable from the original
faith of islam may allah protect us and
may allah give them guidance
about true islam that's why you have so
many when you point out these what are
the arguments
of many christians who don't they refuse
to
decorate the trees they refuse to
participate
in these commercialized holidays and
what arguments do they make they have
the same argument alhamdulillah as we
are making
that celebrating the birth of christ is
uh not there in the bible jesus never
celebrated
you know one time these people the amish
people they came to the mcc masjid
there was a big delegation all the
ladies they were wearing the hijab
i asked them the question why are you
covering your
hair how come you're wearing you know
the hijab and they said right away we
are following the bible
to the letter literally they're
following the bible because it says in
the first corinthians
chapter 11 verse number 5 and 6 they
said they are following it
so if our christian brothers and sisters
if they also
i mean obviously we don't want them to
follow the bible but the quran but even
if they look into the bible they will
find out
that the faith of jesus is not
christianity or not trinity
it was absolute monotheism and all the
rest of the things did not celebrated
birthdays he used to fast the way that
we are fasting
prayed the way with suju the way that we
pray so if they even if they follow the
bible
they have no option but to come to islam
inshallah
what about the orthodox christians the
orthodox christians they
celebrate the birthday of jesus not on
the 25th
because they follow the julian calendar
they celebrate it
on the 6th of january they still
celebrate it
but there's a difference of about 11
days
so they're still committing shirk they
are still uh you know
doing innovation even in their faith by
celebrating
yeah this is very interesting now when
you come to uh
you come to the topic of santa claus you
know
and the the moral message what are your
thoughts on that because
obviously it's based around a lie
children there's no santa claus
yo mama or your dad you bought them
presents
but then okay can an intention that
what's the intention
but then how's the intention intertwined
with just lying to kids
right yeah of course uh
you know in islam the intention has to
be right and the methodology has to be
right
both of them has to be correct so even
though
the even though the person of saint
nicholas
was historically he was a person he used
to be good to the kids giving presents
helping the widows the orphans
that's fine there are many good
christians who were good to humanity
and there are many muslims but we don't
want to build up around the person of
santa claus you know i mean
there is no christmas if you don't see
santa anywhere in the mall on the houses
so now this person of santa is becoming
somewhat like an idol
to them and then on top of it you're
right
the all the lies that the kids are being
told
that you know he lives on the north pole
he
you know write letters to him and there
are tons of letters you know all
throughout the year
i mean every year millions of them
people write
so it is built on a lie so how can you
build
you know give deceive your own children
tell them the truth
and you know let them then choose
so but building on a lie about a person
the intention may be good but the
methodology is 100 percent
not only going against the quran and
basic human logic and you know etiquette
going against their own bible too yeah
we also if we look at now inside
the community the the ummah now we come
back
and we can take i mean you can kind of
contrast here
same thing where a lot of these things
it's just a
good intention for some people but then
narrating certain stories
yeah that might be just totally out
there and i you've had people like
they'll hear from certain [ __ ] right
and the person is not quoting let's say
quran
you know authentic sources authentic you
know material that we have that's what
we base
our dinan these authentic sources right
traceable all the ways the science
behind it
but he's telling they're telling things
that you know um
for somebody like they can't wrap their
minds around some fables some stories
but they have no authenticity and then
the person comes to
realize like hold on if he's based his
whole dean on unauthentic things
unauthentic stories
stories that are way out there i'm sure
you've heard it yeah right
so what lessons can we take from that
also then it becomes at the end it's
also a lie
it can be based on a lot you know what i
mean sure sure so for that reason
i always advise to my family and the
students and my to myself obviously
that if you see any lecture if you see
any lecture or read any book
always try to look for if there is
evidence to that statement
or any statement any concept if there is
no evidence
coming from the quran or the authentic
sunnah it is perhaps just an opinion of
a person
it may be right or it may be wrong so
it's really important for us we only
have two sources of islam
the quran and the authentic sunnah of
muhammad peace be upon him
so we need to hold fast to it because if
we go in the direction of you know
uh unverified uh stories
that means we may have the right
intention but then people may think that
you know perhaps they're coming from the
quran in the sunnah
and that itself would be incorrect yeah
let me give you like an example the
person will say well
well my sheikh i seen him levitating up
you know in the air
or he's been able to be here and then
also
at the kaaba at the same time making
tawaf yeah emotionally you know some
people may get emotional about it
wow our shaykh is you know spiritual and
he's
given so many miracles but then
he's a human he cannot be in two places
number one so that itself you know it
goes against quran sunnah
you know just human logic so it's
important for us for any child any youth
any family any muslim listening to this
that always always look for evidence
and if it goes against the quran and the
authentic sunnah
just reject it yeah as simple as that
yeah
because if we not what will happen to us
is exactly what happens to
happen to the christians they were given
the message of tawhid the oneness of
allah
and they had the book the in jail and
the sunnah of prophet jesus peace be
upon him
they moved away from it so they left
islam
and now they are called christians not
muslims anymore
may allah protect us and our project
progeny from it
i mean i mean this is so important to
stick to the verifiable authentic
sources the verbatim word of god
almighty
allah the quran and then you have the
authentic
sayings traditions reports of the last
and final messenger
sent to mankind prophet muhammad peace
and blessings be upon him and this is
what uh
one of my first teachers you know i'm
also uh dr amir lee you remember
yeah yes yeah yeah you benefited from
him
he's my main teacher if i can say one
year yes so for both of us i remember he
would always
have a statement and very simple we can
pass this along when someone brings you
something ask what's the basis
remember that he would say we have to
ask what's the basis where is this from
right so that's the beautiful thing
about our dean tell us uh
we also see from an environmental aspect
you talk about you know the 40 plus
million
trees that are cut down yearly the
commercialization
you know it's been turned into just
big money you know big industry what do
you have to say about that
well when i said 40 million this is just
in the usa
don't forget the whole the whole world
right i mean just multiply that by many
times let's just say 200 million each
year
and that according to the
environmentalist it is causing uh
increase in the greenhouse gases loss of
the habitat for the species
for the plant and the animal species uh
the erosion of the soil
that also brings the dryness in the air
that also brings
the the forest fires all of these can be
contributing
when we cut down that many trees by
millions actually
then what happens most of them are left
on the curb some of them are recycled
some of them are destroyed it's
it's uh increasing our you know refill
areas
so all of these are kind of damaging the
environment also
first and foremost it doesn't have
anything from the bible the bible
contradicts it
on top of it it's causing a harm to the
environment
wow what about the commercialization you
know the big business that really
revolves around this
uh holiday yeah that's quite unfortunate
i mean this is a billion or trillion
dollar business
that uh i would say must much of this is
wastage
if you look at the amount of uh the
lightning out there the decoration that
they do the investment of time and money
and all of that
that money could have been spent to feed
the poor to take away from the national
debt
for example to give insurance to the
uninsured
you know poor and there are 50 million
poor people in the usa
look at the homeless people that money
could have been well spent
so you know just uh making it into
a business itself the holiday and people
you know
we need to realize where it is coming
from
and what is happening we need to wake up
and not just go with the flow as they
say
yeah yeah is it true that at one point
in history one of the president was the
president roosevelt
yes that he actually what did he
prohibited the decorating of trees in
the white house
is that correct yes in 1902 president
the first roosevelt right not the second
one the roosevelt the first roosevelt
theodore roosevelt in 1902 as he became
the president he want to set an example
to the rest of america and maybe to the
world that cutting of the trees is not
right
it's damaging the environment so he said
no tree should be coming in the
coming to the white house no decoration
so he prohibited for those four years
but some people you know they they took
it some people they did not but
unfortunately there was so much pressure
on the future precedence it now became a
tradition
in the white house to have the tree yeah
yeah that's very unfortunate
so you make the argument here it's
really solid uh
that you had the earlier christians
from the first you know from jesus's
time you established that
obviously he didn't celebrate it you
also have the
for the first two centuries it was
something that was prohibited
so these christians who don't celebrate
christmas they also
uh talk about this being a did you say a
pagan holiday
hello friends pastor doug batchelor here
there is nothing in the bible
that tells us that jesus was born the
25th of december
number 25 is more than likely not the
actual birth date
of jesus christ we understand that we
get that it has pagan origins and all of
those things
yes yeah and you gave some history to
that but
what is actually in the bi if that's not
in the bible you talk about
why is the tree specifically in the
bible the tree right right uh
so the pagans before before prophet
jesus peace be upon him
they used to have their own rituals and
one of the rituals they used to do
to celebrate their own idols idols right
it's very important the word idol is
there
associating with the tree in the bible
so in the book of jeremiah in the old
testament
it says in chapter number 10 verse
number 3 4 and 5
i'm just paraphrasing so i have it here
anyway so this is the bible
so it says in there that the customs
of the people are worthless they're
false
that's the word issues right they're
false that they
go to the forest they cut down a tree
they bring the tree they decorate the
tree
and they hold it so it does not move
then it continues
that these idols are like
the cucumber these idols are like the
scale
scarecrows like in the cucumber feed uh
field
they cannot speak they cannot be carried
they have to be carried away they cannot
walk they cannot benefit
so the bible itself is saying that
decorating of the trees
is the way of the idol worshipers do not
do it equating that to idol worship
on top of it the first commandment says
actually
in the ten commandments the second
commandment speaks about
how they should not make any image of
anything on the land anything on the air
anything beneath the sea
that is also forbidden so any which way
that will look at it this is a pagan
celebration
if the christians knew about it they
would run away from celebrating with the
christmas tree
in fact they will look into the message
of jesus
that is the absolute oneness of god this
is uh this is very important because for
some people it could be so
sensitive and again our intention our
intention is not to uh
hurt anybody's feelings or insult
anybody uh but
just point out some obvious facts and
it's just it's a shame we live in
a time day and age where sometimes you
point these things out instead of
somebody like someone points out hey
there you you let's say you're trying
someone's adding one plus one is
five but they say hold on let me show
you actually one plus one is actually
two it's not
three right and you would be honored or
you'd be happy like say
man wow thank you for yeah or you're
going the wrong direction you're about
to hit a dead end and
say hold up hold hold hey man there's a
the bridge is out you're gonna fall you
actually got to go this way
and man the guy person just saved your
life what about saving your soul your
salvation so
what do you think it is you know
sometimes it's cognitive dissonance you
know people have like you bring the
truth and they just like oh they've been
programmed programmed so much to believe
in something
right so how do you address this point
you know because sometimes it's just
like
the facts are there this is you read
this passage it's just so clear
yeah yeah you know but then how do you
how do you get people
um we want the best for all of mankind
we want
god's guidance allah's guidance for
everybody but how do you cross this road
when you hit it
you know one of the fundamental
obligations that allah has given to us
is the obligation of enjoining good and
forbidding evil not just enjoining good
because
people enjoying good if somebody is
doing good they just take part in it
they encourage them to congratulate them
but our creator has also given us the
obligation
also to forbid evil every single
messenger every single prophet peace be
upon all of them
they used to prohibit if they see
something evil something seen up there
they used to prohibit the people in the
nicest of the words the best packaging
of the message the best example
so allah has given us the label in
chapter number three surah 3 ayah number
110
that you are the best of nations created
for humanity
you mean the muslims that you enjoin
good and you forbid evil and you believe
in allah
so both has to be done obviously using
hikmah
the right play the the right place the
right time so it can connect their
hearts and minds
so forbidding evil is equally important
as enjoying good
so we should not forget it if we forget
it evil is going to just you know
just multiply yeah it is going to
consume us
our families and our future generations
so for any and all of these it's an
obligation
to protect ourselves also and to protect
our future generations
how do you like to answer because we've
we we we see some actual muslims also
who
who talk about how no no no
it's just about good character you know
and you we shouldn't even be
correcting people or talking we need to
work on ourselves that's all what it's
about you need to
purify your heart brother yeah well i
mean
for any disagreement between us and any
muslim or anyone we need to go back to
the quran in the sunnah
allah mentions in the quran the prophet
is the best example for us to follow
so not only he was the best role model
in humanity walking talking you know the
truthful the honest
but by his actions and by his words he
used to convey the message
and he used to correct the people and he
used to invite the non-muslims so when
he
was with the muslims he used to make
their iman strong
but when he was out on the street he
used to invite people
to the worship of one god stay away from
the idols
you know follow the rules the guidance
follow the quran
so he used to do both simultaneously
make muslims better invite non-muslims
to islam
if he is the best example we should
follow him right
like a two wheels of a bicycle yeah so
both are needed
so there's no doubt obviously that
should be by default that work because
the prophet saws
he said that i have not been sent except
to perfect good character so that we're
all works in progress but you can't just
use that
you know uh excuse to now uh
not fulfill your obligation of at least
conveying to what you know
the message giving someone some
direction you know if they if it's
needed forbidding good
you know in the best in the best manner
possible
of course of course uh you know in fact
there is a hadith
sayings of one of the saints of muhammad
peace be upon him
this is in imam tabarani's collection
some companions ana's big and has been
malik
he came and asked the prophet that how
can we enjoy
good and forbid evil when we ourselves
are not doing it hundred percent
so the prophet said even then go and
join good and forbid evil
so we need to work on ourselves and we
also need to go in
and join good and forbid evil there is
no point in which i can say now i'm
hundred percent good let me go out now
it will never happen they will never
happen that muslims are now hundred
percent
now let's go out and do dawah to
non-muslims even in the time of muhammad
peace be upon him there were some
muslims
a few of them who were committing sins
even then the prophet
that just did not invest at 100 percent
here
making them hundred percent good before
going out to the non-muslims no
he instructed them he gave them the
proper terbia and simultaneously used to
go out
so it has to be both not either or yeah
yeah
i mean this is just very clear you have
the example
in the in the life of prophet muhammed
his whole life
was about that one inviting people right
in the best manners
to uh connect them to the creator of
heaven's earth this is you know
the pure monotheism and then the example
of all the other prophets it's just that
when you read the quran that's their
whole mission is
calling people uh to islam to
have a relationship with the created
heavens and earth to obey him to follow
their teachings that he sent through
them but then
you also have now we have the evidence
in the quran
how about this wonderful example of the
sabbath breakers
in the quran what happened to them and
those who were inviting
right and then the other ones were just
like why are you doing that why are you
wasting your time
just on the sidelines right so it's
important islam or muslims we are not
just
supposed to be you know on the sidelines
we should be just on the main stage
and joining good for beating evil the
results are not in our hand
we just with a good words good character
good deeds we need to let them know what
is right and what is wrong
if they obey it then that's fine it's
good between them
if they don't you know at least we have
done our job
and all this can be done i mean
obviously you have charity organizations
right
that's a form of dawah you know what i
mean in there whatever which way i mean
but it's it's a vast way but obviously
if it's within the bounds of quran and
sunnah but
the the point here is you can't just you
know
um worry just about yourself and your
development but then you're not worried
about
your neighbor you know your colleagues
your friends and those people you talk
about everything under the sun as i
often say you'll talk about baseball
football
everything else but you won't mention
the purpose of life
at one no point in that conversation for
years you're going to be held
accountable no
you know just give the analogy of fire
right yeah or give it or give a pamphlet
or something just in a book
sure there are so many different ways
suppose if there's a fire in the whole
neighborhood
you can take care of your home only and
not worry about it
but then eventually as you're sleeping
god forbid the outside fire may
eventually come to your home and affect
you and your children and your family
may allah protect us
so we have to take care of the fires
within our homes and the fires outside
of the home
not only for us to be safe for the
community to be safe
so any which way that you look at it if
we just be
just ourselves just in the masjid then
just praying we have to do all of them
but we need to make sure that we become
a force of good in the society
you know if there's evil going on if the
evil multiplies our children would be
exposed to it
it will become a norm for them and then
we may be thinking how come they are
behaving this way talking this way
believing that way
is because we have not given them the
proper empowerment
about what is going on in the world and
we are not being ambassadors of peace
and goodness in the world so any which
way that we dissect it
we have to follow the prophet's example
work on ourselves work on the muslims
and also work on the bigger society yeah
yeah yeah this is important when someone
talks about just good
good mannerisms i mean if you link that
that should be your sponsor to that
should be islam they should know that
this is islam that's helping to become
good to my neighbor to be good for
instrument for the development of a
better society this is because of islam
because people
think like okay as is often stated that
oh he's
good because he came here and he's
civilized now because we civilized him
you know what i mean
it's because of our culture no no you
have to identify it back
to the dean this is uh very important
yes yes
of course tell me uh also so the actual
message now we covered all this
the actual message of all the prophets
including jesus peace be upon him who we
believe was one of the mightiest
messengers ever sent
and this is something that when we talk
about his original message
i often because a lot of times you got
to just layers and layers
of of the of lies deception
cover-up you know you know suppression
of the truth but
when you have back in bosnia in europe
in the heart of europe this is where my
family's from
they had the unitarian christians at
that time and i often make this point so
people can relate like this is not
something so
uh far out there for the other or the
other it's something so close to home
and it was when the actual message
of jesus came to the balkans came to the
bosniaks right of that time there was
like 60
000 of them and they didn't believe you
know
the common things that were you know the
church was doing
but then islam came and fit like a glove
and the actual message of jesus the pure
message of jesus
to these unitarian christians these
bhajans at that time was delivered
and they accepted it so what was that
actual message of jesus
well the actual message is present in
the quran surah number three chapter
number three verse number 51
in the law
so jesus peace be upon him he's quoted
in the quran and allah is saying that
jesus said that verily
allah is my lord and your lord worship
him alone and that is the straight path
and that was the message of jesus peace
be upon him he did not came to
preach trinity actually the quran is
against trinity
uh he was empowered by by god to do the
miracles
so just because jesus did miracles does
not make him more special than any
prophet
prophets and messengers they were given
the power the miracles by the creator
himself
like jesus peace be upon him he used to
raise people from the dead
he used to give eyesight to the blind
the leopards he spoke when he was a baby
every single miracle does not make jesus
special the focus should be the creator
and his soul message according to the
bible too perhaps you may have read this
mark chapter 12 verse number 28 a person
came to jesus and asked him a million
dollar question
that of all the commandments which one
is the first the greatest
and jesus peace be upon him he said hear
o israel the lord our god is only one
worship him with all your heart mind
soul and strength and that is the first
commandment
worship him right not worship me so that
is the message of jesus
so as some people in history they
embraced that truth the absolute oneness
of god preached by jesus
some people moved away those who moved
away
they form the whole faith of
christianity around the person of jesus
but the faith of jesus was the faith of
islam
submission to one god so god then sent
allah then send his final prophet
muhammad peace be upon him
to bring these people and the rest of
humanity
again back to the fall of islam so we
say to our christian brothers and
sisters
if you love jesus follow the faith of
jesus the faith of jesus is the
submission to the one creator
quote unquote islam i mean this is
straightforward when people look into
islam and they see this simple message
worship one and only one god do not
associate partners with him
yeah and be morally upright it's just
straightforward it's simple to
understand
nothing convoluted very lucid and clear
no trinity no trying to make something
you know got into it and this is
going back to santa claus and going back
to christmas and everything and
most people even turn towards atheism
disbelief because they start to
imagine okay what they've been brought
up to believe that
god the father is some old man with a
beard
you know in the heavens and then he has
his son
jesus and then you have some like holy
ghost smoke and then no matter how hard
you try to make these
three one it just doesn't fit it becomes
very uh strenuous on the heart to soul
because your innate
disposition you know to only worship god
the unseen creator that has an earth
with the most perfect names and
attributes the most loving the most kind
and most just the most merciful
but you cannot anything you look at that
cannot be god that's creation
so when you deliver this it's so
beautiful
when you deliver this pure message this
was the purity
of the monotheism at that time you know
with
jesus and his followers as moses and his
followers and the last in front of masha
prophet muhammad now we have it today
and then we have the living miracle the
quran it's just so straightforward and
clear but
um a person would you say has to be what
are the ingredients has to be
seeking the truth it has to be sincere
what what what's the qualities the
formula that it penetrates because you
can deliver all these things
and a person will still reject it i mean
i always say to my christian brothers
and sisters
that always will since your heart and
mind pray to the creator and inshallah
he will
he will guide you and many questions
that you may have when you are reading
your own bible
you know how can god be one in three
three in one how can god be up there
god coming down god dying who is going
to run the universe
why does god have a son why not a
daughter right why discrimination
so many of the questions our christian
brothers and sisters that they have as
they read the bible
the quran answers them that god is only
one in one jesus is not the creator you
know just makes sense separating creator
from the creation
the questions that they may have if this
is the word of god
then how come the solutions to many
problems humanity is going
through so the quran responds to the
questions
with the solutions so for the theology
for the concept of god for the person of
jesus solutions for humanity
salvation going to paradise all of them
are neatly worked out in the quran
given by the creator so when they look
into the quran they will find
purpose they will find peace they will
find solutions inshallah
beautiful that's what every human being
should strive to know
what's my purpose in life what am i
living for yeah and where am i going
when i die
because we're gonna die we're gonna lead
this life and now is the time
to get it right so tell us for those
muslims out there
who are you know you often get this
question around this time of the year
can what's wrong with me you know saying
merry christmas can i say merry
christmas
that's one of the questions i'm sure you
get a lot right right
so we cannot say merry christmas because
if you know the realities
of the word christ and the word jesus
what do they mean by that
actually they mean him to be divine god
son of god and the quran is against that
the quran says that the biggest shirk
associating partners with god
so when we are happy in their
celebrations we are
actually encouraging them to go on
committing more shirk
when we are saying merry christmas we
are saying mary shirk
or happy shirk right i mean i just have
to be blunt this is how
what it is the best we can do is we can
say happy holidays
that is much more benign and neutral
compared to saying merry christmas
well that's important point i mean have
that stick in your head and again this
is not to disparage on anybody and we
made that example in the beginning you
can't expect you know
someone to jump into the hindu to
celebrate
eid right as you're sacrificing let's
say a cow
or expect him to eat a beef burger right
you can't expect the hindu to eat a beet
burger we're not going to get upset
about that right because
he now feels that this is his god the
cow for instance
so now you are transgressing on his
right so no one should force
you as a muslim to go ahead and say mary
shirk
that's and this is that's how it is i'm
sorry i have to say that way but
you're saying mary shirk uh so and this
is said with
all due respect and
and again we pointed out we're just
going in line with what christians are
actually also
many who are not celebrating also and
they're linking it back to
different rituals that have nothing to
do with the actual teachings of jesus
peace be upon him what about parties
you know this time of year not at work
you get invited to a lot of parties
right right muslims their colleagues
there's so much pressure to come to a
quote-unquote christmas party i would
discourage any muslim from going there
because it's not just you know quote
unquote fun but they're going to call
you a party pooper now
well actually some people they will
respect you if you stand up to your
principles
seriously but you have some even some
imam some chefs who you know will
say there's nothing wrong with saying
merry christmas or you know as long as
you don't drink alcohol you can go to
the party
well in the party what may happen
suppose it's a christmas party
there is a lot of free mixing there can
be
food up there that we cannot eat people
would be drinking
if it's an actual christmas party they
would be breaking the bread drinking the
wine
that symbolizes drinking or eating the
body of jesus
and drinking the blood of jesus right
all of these things
are shirk so we should we should
not encourage ourselves from going there
just nice and polite
be to your boss to your employer to your
colleagues you're respected but i have
other commitments
um you know so happy holidays
and now this is not to not negate if if
you want to invite
that same person to your house on
another occasion
you know and talk about some
important matters you know give some
dollars something is there something
wrong with that
no inviting them to our homes is fine if
they are comfortable
and hopefully that may spark some
conversations about islam when they see
the calligraphy on their wall
when they see that you only have halal
food or you know
healthy food they may be thinking you
know where is my pork chops or what is
you know wine and whatever so things
that they see in the house
things that they see your kids are
saying you know salaam alaikum or
you see a prayer rug up there the copy
of the quran there
all of these may spark in the non-muslim
brother or sister
about asking questions this can be a way
for them to introduce islam so you can
invite inshallah if you're comfortable
and statistically if you look i mean
you'd want you know because
this is where it's important you you are
having the best manners with your
neighbor
you know muslim are non-muslim
definitely and then that non-muslim not
yet muslim neighbor knows that hold on
man i wouldn't want no other neighbor
because this is a muslim is one
who you can sincerely trust you can
trust them you know with your property
you know you can trust him you know
nowadays with all the adultery and all
the stuff that's happening
you don't have to worry about this
muslim neighbor you know uh committing
uh zen our fornication with your wife
this is rampant
even looking at your wife improperly
right yeah yeah
he won't even touch your wife or even
shake her hand that's how to the level
of respect he goes that muslim right
and he's honest he's somebody that now
you feel like man this is someone when i
leave uh
town or anything that's someone who i
know will safeguard my house my property
and you're honored to have a muslim as a
neighbor yeah yeah and the and the
muslim kids they're not doing any drugs
no boyfriend no girlfriend right uh they
are respectful
they run to you when you need help
you're shoveling the snow they come
there to help you out
this is a blessing i mean this is
priceless they had you on the news for
that right
yeah you were on the news actually some
of you
there was a just real briefly we got a
few more minutes what happened
and you went to some of the muslim um
some of the non-muslim neighbors
and then you asked if they needed
anything because it was like uh below
below zero and the snow was high what
was the story real quick
yeah it was the polar vortex i went with
you to that what was that
the nbc station or what show was that
yeah it was the windy city
yeah i know you feel kind of shy about
talking about but the thing is you know
those things should not make the news
that is expected from a muslim to a
non-muslim from a neighbor to a neighbor
what should make the news if someone is
not helping out yes
right it's not about me i mean islam is
encouraging us to do it
so you did it why because of who's
teaching you to do this i mean prophet
muhammad peace be upon him okay right
i mean there's a there's a narration in
which muhammad peace be upon him he said
you're not a full believer if you eat
your full your neighbors are hungry
so looking out for the neighbors helping
the neighbor this is part of islam the
prophet did it
and we are supposed to follow it so you
know it should not have made the news
what should make the news is the people
are not helping out very important yeah
very important
yes that is news right this is just part
of humanity it's not just being
muslim and just being a human means to
help other humans
what about those families now that they
uh are used to having their
their get-togethers and now you have a
lot of new muslims right those who have
uh
looked for the purpose of life they
found it in islam submission to the
creator not the creation
they looked at all the overwhelming
evidence in the quran
and they found you know this is an
intelligent decision that i'm making
that okay islam is the truth it's not
blind belief
they've accepted it but now there's this
hurdle now this is that first first
christmas
how should they proceed sure sure this
question of
is often asked that i'm a new muslim can
i attend christmas parties my family's
inviting me right my mom and dad
i would say definitely go there because
if you don't go there
you are breaking up the families you
don't want to give the perception
that islam came to break up the no islam
came to unite the families
however the disclaimer is this as you go
there
take part in the social activities you
know hug them shake their hands smile at
them
but do not take part in the spiritual
activities singing of the hymns
reading from the bible breaking the
bread and drinking the wine or
calling the name of jesus in in the name
of jesus stay away from the spiritual
activities or anything which is
forbidden to eat and drink
but just be there in the room with them
if they're doing something spiritual
just be a little bit aside greet them
with happy holidays for example
or give them the happy holiday gifts and
take that opportunity
really important that why you are muslim
what you believe about jesus peace be
upon him
who knows people may be enlightened and
who knows allah may guide them
so go there islam came not to break the
families
but to unite the families
uh jazokai thank you very much is there
anything else that you think is
important this time of year
that we didn't cover that you think that
is important that it needs to to be
heard
well the only summary or the message
that we can give to our own muslims
that allah has given you the best of all
the deens
the only deen that was being practiced
by all the prophets and the messengers
so the best gift that you can give to
your neighbors yes you can give a box
and cookies and candies and all of that
the best gift that you can give to your
neighbors to the non-muslims
is the gift of islam so that's one thing
second thing
protect your family protect your
children protect the muslims
because there's so much distraction
so much uh you know for the sake of fun
we can be gravitating towards
what they are doing so we need to be
strong on what does the quran in the
sunnah teaches
so instill that education in the people
in the muslims
and then become ambassadors of peace
that's an obligation for you allah will
hold us responsible on the day of
judgement
may allah protect us may allah guide our
non-muslim brothers and sisters
and help us to be the peace makers in
the society
with that video we started off with this
is
important what you're saying is
basically be grounded in your deen
know your deen right if you don't and
stand up for the truth because if you
don't stand up for the truth you'll fall
for anything as the saying goes
so that's why you fall into many of
these deviations because you're not
grounded in the deen
you're not standing up for the truth and
that truth doesn't
cause you to be belligerent or be unkind
to
those who are not of the same faith
right it actually causes you to be the
kindest
exactly exactly i mean we have to be
confident that islam allah has given us
this is the best deen
we have to be confident if we are not
confident our kids are not going to be
confident
so knowledge is important practice is
important sharing is important
and may allah help us in doing all of
these yeah and at the end of the day the
guidance i mean comes from the creator
that happens on earth allah so
uh if at least if you're sharing you can
try to you know to your adept character
and relaying the truth
you know you had the as alpha and make
this example you have uh
uh you had abu talib right he didn't
accept islam but then you had abu jahl
so at least you know with your neighbors
and friends now they get to see
you living islam and they see really
what islam is
and then you've removed one more abu
jahl that's out there you know
of course we see this happening all the
time don't we yeah yeah
and a good quranic ayah for us to you
know
end the show with is the ayah from surah
16 surah nahal
ayah number 125
and good preaching and converse with
them in ways which are best and most
gracious
with a smile empathy compassion concern
for them
attachment to allah following the sunnah
with
all of these mindset invite our
non-muslim brothers and sisters to islam
and that's the best gift we can give it
to them if somebody's out there he's a
christian
and he like likes what we're talking
about where can they get more
information
uh some pamphlets some books a free
quran they can get their game piece
yes our non-muslim brothers and sisters
you can go to the gainpeace.com website
and over there you can get a free copy
of the quran english or spanish
you can get brochures you can get a book
on the life of prophet muhammad peace be
upon him
even for our muslim brothers and sisters
if you want
brochures about jesus peace be upon him
about prophet muhammad
about the quran you can get this extra
if you go to the gain peace.com
slash store obtain them keep it on your
person on your purse in your pocket in
your homes
opportunity arises pass it on to them
read them first and foremost for your
children
and pass it on to them and that is the
best gift the gift of islam we can give
to humanity
thank you and we'll end with the
greetings of jesus and all the
messengers peace be with you
and if you like this episode of the dean
show like this video
share this video far and wide and
support us on our patreon page so we can
continue this work
thank you for tuning in peace be with
you assalamu alaikum
subscribe right now